[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing severus
snape harry potter
and one of their first encounters in
snape's first year
potions class more specifically we're
going to be discussing a theory
involving a secret message that snape
may have relayed to harry when they
first met
the moment occurred right at the
beginning of the series
in harry potter and the philosopher's
stone when harry first
sits down in snape's potions class
already suspicious of snape
snape makes it very clear right away
that he does not
like harry mocking him as hogwarts new
celebrity
right before quizzing him on the spot
about different magical herbs
in spite of his fame harry had known
nothing of the wizarding world
until very recently and this meant that
he had no chance of being able to answer
snape's questions
this is something that snape undoubtedly
knew hoping to make harry
look foolish there will be no foolish
wand waving or silly incantations in
this class
as such i don't expect many of you to
appreciate
the subtle science and exact art that is
potion making
however for those select few who possess
the predisposition
i can teach you how to bewitch the mind
and ensnare the senses
i can tell you how to bottle fame brew
glory
and even but a stopper in death then
again
maybe some of you have come to hogwarts
in possession of abilities
so formidable that you feel confident
enough to not
pay attention mr potter our new
celebrity tell me what would i get if i
added powdered root of asphadel to an
infusion of wormwood
you don't know well let's try again
where mr potter
would you look if i asked you to find me
a bizarre
and what is the difference between
monkswood and wolfsbane
pity clearly fame isn't everything
is it mr potter at first glance all this
dialogue shows us is that snape
wants to bully harry a bit he's
purposely asking harry questions
to which he does not know the answer
however the theory that i want to
discuss
suggests that snape's questions are
actually relaying
a secret message to harry however it's
not a message that he ever expected
harry to understand
snape is a complex individual and the
message in question
was simply for himself let's dissect
snape's
secret message his first question to
harry is
what would i get if i added powdered
root of asphadel to an infusion of
wormwood
and what's curious about this is that
according to the victorian flower
language
asphodel is actually a type of lily this
lily means
my regrets follow you to the grave and
the second part of snoop's question
wormwood means absence which is
symbolized by sorrow
combined this could be interpreted as i
bitterly regret
lily's death and this is of course
significant
because lily is harry's mother the only
woman that snape
ever loved deep right to add to this
even further
snape's question even contains an
allusion to his own death
as asfidel was once believed to be a
cure
for snake bites which of course snape
eventually dies from
did you guys know about this theory
already it's been around on the internet
for a while
but i wanted to relay it to you all and
see what you thought do you think that
this
hidden message was legitimately and
purposely integrated by rowling
or is this just the result of a little
too much overanalyzing
by fans let me know in the comment
section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry